Attorney General William Barr confirmed
he will look at how the Russia
investigation started in 2016
Barr also told a Senate Appropriations
Subcommittee yesterday that he thinks
somebody spied on president Trump's
campaign but he modified that claim
under questioning from some Democrats I
want to give you a chance to rephrase
something you said because I think when
the Attorney General of the United
States uses the word spying it's rather
provocative and in my view unnecessarily
inflammatory I just want to make it
clear looking at thinking back on all
the different colloquy here that I am
NOT saying that improper surveillance
occurred I'm saying that I am concerned
about it and looking into it that's all
there was such focus on that word
because President Trump has used the
word spy Democratic House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi responded saying Barr was quote
going off the rails
she said Barr should remember that he is
the Attorney General of the United
States not the Attorney General of
Donald Trump major Garrett is at the
White House where the president went
further than Barr by accusing the FBI of
targeting his campaign major good
morning good morning president Trump
said here yesterday the
counterintelligence investigation that
eventually led the appointment of
Special Counsel Robert Muller was an
attempted coup the president said more
alleging treason was committed by dirty
cops and Trump haters direct quotes all
among those he named former FBI
officials James Comey and Andrew McCabe
the president went on to say his
supporters are hungry to prosecute those
who launched the 1st 2016 probe into
possible Russian connections to the
Trump campaign now Attorney General
William Barr sounded as if he was ready
to follow the president's lead by
indicating he would investigate the
investigation and at one point Barr
stunned senators on that panel when he
said he thought there had been spying on
mr. Trump's campaign
he then backtracked admitting he had no
direct evidence of wrongdoing or
meritless surveillance Democrats accused
Barr of protecting President Trump and
in the process undermining his own
credibility days before Barr is
scheduled to release a much
broader review or contents thereof of
the Muller report and even some
Republican senators were perplexed by
bars overall testimony in the main
president Trump knows the more doubts he
can so about the Muller investigation
and its origins the more he can combat
any evidence that might emerge
suggesting wrongdoing Norah it's an
excellent point
an analysis major thank you as always